j'aime c'est un jeu en fait on envoie
des comédiens sur un lieu qu'ils
connaissent pas et on a une journée pour
faire tourner un ce cas je l'écrirai
tourner un sketch
week-end car l'aventuré commence à saint
mandé on aurait pu trouver plus
plus dangereux comme blade je me demande
bien où on va quand même
j'étais il ya deux jours ne seraient pas
en gros je savais tout est sale et oui
dans sa vie tranquille et qu'on roule et
cannes et jérôme savent toujours pas où
ils vont j'ai remis moi je sais un peu
parce que je qu'il faut aborder tout à
l'heure je vais éviter de bordés de
haies rien dire c'est ce qui me fait
marrer aussi dans dallas et ce côté un
peu je un peu fort boyard
peut-on prédire et que lopez
on est parti vers le parc astérix et
donc bout d'un moment au bout de très
longtemps d'ailleurs kanafi les paras
par comprendre avec des panneaux
finalement avec * dessus alors qu'anne à
tuléar dit ça on est passé devant
3500 qu'il voit
alors ian napa l'attraction
et la libye oui toute l'équipe était
réunie et julien nous ça nous a fait un
petit brief qu'il a expliqué ce qui
allait se passer
l'américaine on est sur le tournage du
premier jam
voile et tout l'équipement gros et on a
du coup une journée pour faire un sketch
c'est le concept ce soir d'en sortir vu
les images ok et d'evan botha ce serait
bien on a ici les parent dépendant kyan
khojandi on adrien laignel on avait
senti l on à la firme 00 je serai un
petit peu le maître des clés le maître
des jeux le passe partout le dernier
grognard c'est pas été un jour à sion
je vous rappelle les règles ou là ce
soir on part avec un sketch on organise
deux trois handicaps tout à l'heure on
sera obligé des choses qu'ils soient vus
de casey va écouter c'est nickel on se
découvre des corps
ouf quoi on était on était tous ensemble
par après moi j'ai pas du tout participé
à ce projet fut tenue parce qu'ils
tournaient les interviews du coup tourné
au parc astérix et c'était vraiment cool
et surtout qu'ils ont été vraiment
géniaux parce qu'en gros ils ont des
maisons hantées qui utilise que pour
halloween donc hors période d'halloween
en gros on peut tourner dedans
est tout
à l'époque d'épicerie de mon père qui
n'a presque pas changé et l'arrêtent
selon le parc ça ouvre dans quelques
minutes car elle tournait dans un décor
particulier on découvre enfin les frais
lieu une espèce de grand jeu pleine
déprime premiers décors aussi leur a
donné comme possible taille cet honneur
ça sent le caprice des dieux manga
sachant que ici pour moi une paupière
m'en faire une prison située à mallawi
tiens ça se confirme et très vite on
peut avoir l'impression présente loi ou
d'arrêt pour faire les bon alors c'est
vraiment donc je
leur accorde
mais
ils vont chez lui et c'est ici quoi il
aboie c'est le bordel tu fais pas gaffe
donc l'arrivée j'ai dû couler la baille
à la chaise électrique mais qui dit
vas-y assez assieds toi chantier toute
façon une chute d'un pylône électrique
voilà bon tu filmera pas ça parce que il
apparaît donc
après le faire le déjà cette fois ce
constat regard des plastiques durs
s'enfermer dans plaît qu'ims regardé par
les
voilà je voudrais bien le plan sur sa
toile éternelle comme ça
mais ça des zooms un peu juste mais que
fait il à une planche en bois sur lui
autant salut
je vais venir nous a montré de trois
accessoires qui étaient étalés sur le
sol vraiment de tout des flingues des
katanas accessoires il ya
accessoires possible
dubaï pour eux oi premier handicap est
un objet à placer pas facile
iaudio
un cabri guga okani qu'elle
attendait des 4 persos qui fait pourtant
des youyous quoi la prison l'a pas placé
pour le sketch la fin
des costumes pas mal
car voilà faut retenir allait bien
normalement il ya de quoi ouais mon
coffre ou yaya quoi perdu 2 ghz bayat
ordinaire de quoi faire des djeuns dans
le premier handicap do you all indique à
caser le yoyo deuxième handicap j'avais
le bling à caser genre et sur internet
j'ai demandé les gens là oui au monde on
s'est tellement de monde et donc on a
sélectionné la réplique de mississipi
tchèque qui a proposé à son guidon vous
n'avez pas qu'il savait que je savais et
moi non plus haut alors on la refait
parce que j'avais pas ça parce que tu
savais pas qu'ils avaient cuit savez les
moi non plus généralement ça va écrire
le siège ça s'est tellement c'est précis
des là c'est compliqué c'est un celi
tournure voilà dans les handicaps un des
personnage a un frère jumeau une fleur
jeu mais
là vous n'avez quasiment toutes les clés
on peut là la table c'est d'aller voir
d'orient qui a des perruques cas les
accessoires etc donc là on a peu et
produits silicones et compagnie ouais
gros on à silicon est à des lentilles
aux is a way tu as des dents aussi du
coup ouais si jamais si on veut vampires
pour faire des dents un max de perruques
un max de barbiche c'est le fabrique du
palmashow fais gaffe l'ex alliance
nucléaire s'est gorgé d'histoire ben dis
donc
une fois qu'on l'a découvert les décors
les maquillage les costumes les
accessoires maintenant il faut écrire un
sketch vraiment la station ils sont tous
encore en fait il fait cette demande et
de décision et toi t'es vraiment bizarre
comme en plus il peut y avoir une espèce
de gros perso baroudeur et qui
pourraient mourir direct quoi tu sais
très vite on a eu plein d'idées on a
commencé suite à s'amuser et moi on
était plutôt tension dynamique même
comique
si vous comptez sortir décrivant je vous
conseille de m'écoute
quand on est fonds vert pour la
présentation des joueurs de djamel
bakar tueur mais il ya une règle c'est
écriture on parle je suis entre genre ça
commence ils se racontent leurs
anecdotes de tueurs ouais bon d'avoir
plus tard comme ça on profite des décors
voilà quoi
mais j'ai pu t'aider mec mais c'était en
colo ça c'est drôle tu as un mec mais
c'était encore lost était allé très vite
plein de pistes de plein de sketches
après plus dur ça a été de choisir
quelles pistes on est vraiment creuser
et qu'elle puisse qu'on allait mettre de
côté on écoute et on n'a pas envie en
fait de décider en fait n'a pas envie de
dire non tafanel est moins bien où ça
s'est moins bien en fait le problème
c'est qu'on a toujours envie de trouver
de meilleures idées et du coup on
n'avance jamais quoi ici le sketch tue
mais étudie pas il ya déjà mais tout se
passe bien c'est un bon sketch simple
pour ma tête c'est cette image puis 10
or en or jam c'est un métier c'est
chacun pour être oui il faisait 4 l'idée
c'était pas vraiment de faire un peu des
bleus tournaient mais plus dans les
gares damas dans le temps là tu vois on
va être obligé de l'enclos de faire des
propositions il ya des petits stress
qu'on dit qu'il est on se dit qu'il faut
réussir à établir le sketch vous ça
ressemble à quelque chose le sketch
le projet me dit de jouer très vite tu
te rends compte que quatre heures sont
passées et que tu es en taille tu n'as
pas ta humilité mais que t'en as pas à
lui sur lesquels tout le monde est
d'accord ça serait bien qu'on reparte
d'ici dont dix huit avec une situation
qui nous plaît on a dit world enfin tous
les fumeurs on a tous eu le plein
d'idées de gags genre à la hot shots
machin etc la pensée des gens on va
faire ça on va te faire autre chose et
on a que trouver des trucs qu'on avait
besoin d'idées bram le succès on a une
idée on a tous pleins d'idées on les
fait se trouvera un décor l'un des trous
dedans et on n'a pas le décalage le but
du jeu c'est quand même d'aller ainsi
n'en change pas on allait insister sur
les fichiers ou quoique non je viens de
refaire du flip en fait c'est on peut
plus vannes est sur le côté fiction il
n'y a jamais personne qui a tranché pour
dire bon là c'est bon faut faire ça
parce que c'est nous on n'avancera
jamais est-ce qu'on insiste sur cette
idée vu que vingt huit
ans il n'y a pas mille and qu'ils
allaient manger on est battu mais
discutée en mangeant tomorrow il a une
seule ta non du coup on peut surfer un
peu dans les crues du rhin repartant sur
sur l'idée qu' on avait parlé au pam à
landrin qui était la pause clope de
serial killer des idées les plus simples
qu'on a eu jusqu'à présent et celle là
choisir le gym pour l'explication du il
tombe face à bourg la mieux pas mais là
n'était pas au courant que tu savais que
j'étais au courant pour son histoire
on est partis là-dessus et on la
combiner avec d'autres idées qu'on avait
eues qui n'étaient pas forcément liés et
en fait on a eu l'idée d'utiliser ce
dialogue pour faire le lien entre toutes
les idées qu'on avait eues on partirait
sur qui la rend si leur nul est pas bon
killer nul donc au début ça commence
comme ça sur la même durée
illimitée bon
je croyais qu'ils leur expliquent ces
bonnes anecdotes et le mauvais effet
ouais moi je les fais que la crise
économique
moi j'aimerais patata les bonnes places
line moi j'arrive pas comme franck ca va
s'écouler village de faire plein de
juste tu peux pas en revanche inchangée
j'en ai testé plusieurs teintes à plein
de trucs
c'est pas tellement j'ai du mal à
vraiment à trouver là j'ai pas de jeu
pas de coach k et j'en ai essayé
vachement pourtant ils ont situation
alors un petit look salut les p'tits
clous c'est non c'est pas ça des kirghiz
non ça c'est vrai bon j'ai du mal avec
les phrases d'accroché coucou qui sait
que bla ça sort du placard et pour toi
tu pas homosexuel
ou si l'on attend en fait la victime
elle
cherche mon personnage je pense que
c'est pas drôle de le faire un peu tu
vois de faire un peu genre ouais tu vois
il faut que tu fasse gaffe tu prennent
soin de toi je peux arriver genre plus
seul
en fait tu vois faut que tu fasses
attention à toi ta santé tu prennes
d'élite habib sy est modelée l'écriture
est drôle écueil personnage est marrant
à l'écouté ça qui est intéressant tu
n'es jamais flipper en me disant on va
pas y arriver parce que pour moi le
principe de l'exercice c'était d'être
toujours dans l'improvisation et la
démerde quoi commence à essayer de
s'activer on se rend compte qu'on est un
vraiment en retard en fait est que
jérôme doit partir d'une heure comme ça
est ce que est ce qu'on va refaire les
répliques de qian dans la conversation
sans moi
je suis leur stand à faire s'il veut du
à dans la première conversation on est à
trois c'est pour ça que ce lien autriche
donc j'ai le temps de tout et ce après
vous allez voir des revers comme si
j'étais là mais en vo et regardera que
tu regarderas peine sorti chaoui parce
que moi aussi je me casse à 5h
way un quart d'heure blumenstein
génériques américains george tong un
regardeur
chose de très très très très serré la
girouette pendant 50 minutes maria
tourner encore c'est tellement écrit un
mot non on a peut-être perdu un peu
longue de la maison d'avoir déjà fait
d'avoir déjà fini ce qu'on avait déjà
harry sur les blagues jusqu'à ce que ak
et et vincent trouve heureusement une
meilleure fin que savait qu'on avait et
je les prépare sur pc ça ma technique
j'avoue venir et ouais tu as pu venir
parce que tu sais qu'ils savaient que tu
savais a très bien et moi non plus avoir
trouvé des idées rapidement et tout
enfin je trouve ça vraiment stimulant 1
sur 1 1re la première à 80 ok quand tu
veux jouer et actions
bonjour je viens pour le meurtre
sa vibrante de simpson pourrait
bien sortir perdants et on trouve là un
peu plus sec
bah ouais j'aurais vous allez bien voir
combien vous tuer alors là vous êtes
surpris mais la presse vous allez
maintenant qu'en plus surpris de ces
régions avaient coupé la tête
tu me croyais pas j'étais là haut ça non
tu croyais pas parce que j étais juste
derrière leur tu t'y attendais
absolument pas ce soir je vais te tuer
on pourrait presque faire avec mon dos
car il est super fort bienvenu dans le
journal de 20 heures
de fatigue et
vous êtes de fatigue
donc on s'active on tourne au sketch en
vue de pompeux tout en s'amusant
ok ensuite moi j'arrive pas si j'ai truc
là j'ai vraiment du mal avec les
punchlines italien et qualité
c'est important aussi c'est la mise en
scène il faudra pas oublier ça se
travaille illustré autonome genre tu es
là tu crois pas que c'est un peu l'effet
qui est dans les dents le scribe ya
toujours un double fait ils ont toujours
à double sens et culture partout lui
contester
à quoi
on a fini par faire un sketch scénarisé
en une journée en fait alors que le
concept de juin pour moi c'est vraiment
on a une situation on tourne et après on
s'amuse on rajoute des vannes était déjà
très proche d'un truc très aboutie on
n'y a pas énormément choses à améliorer
je pense que maintenant julien a une
idée le prêt de ce qui vaut certes
promis pour les prochains mois impose la
plus de choses qui déraille à prendre et
là-dessus au pouvoir s'éclater si les
gens qui font je pense qu'on fera un jam
e épisode 2 et ça ressemblera tellement
pas au premier en fait si on veut
survivre il m'écoute
victorieux si vous comptez sortir des
survivants je suis conseils de mes coups
vous avez regardé ya main et je vous en
remercie
soixante irène cascadeur
en streaming
chacun de jeu de calage dégueulasse
suivi mais dégueulasse